(boat motor running)
- [Wes] He's comin' at ya.
Florida gators aren't afraid of much.
They're certainly not afraid of me.
But we're here to protect them
from something they should be scared of.
He definitely isn't happy to see us.
A sneaky little lizard from Argentina.
I'm Wes Larson, a wildlife
biologist and lover
of the outdoors for as
long as I can remember.
I'm traveling the country to find
the next generation of conservationists.
The people on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet and protect
the animals we share it with.
(boat motor starting up)
(boat motor running)
My first stop takes me all the way down
to the southern wilds of Florida
also known as the Everglades.
They're huge, hot, and home to
one of the fiercest
predators on the planet:
The American alligator.
These researchers from
the University of Florida
have taken me deep into the swamp
to survey the local gator population.
- [Researcher] Well, we got a gator.
- Cool.
Wow, let’s see, gosh.
I just gotta say, ever since I was a kid,
I fantasized about coming to Florida
and meeting alligators up close.
Alligators are at the
top of the food chain.
Crucial to maintaining the
ecological balance of the Everglades.
But despite this dominance,
alligators are under threat
from a foreign invader
that no one saw coming:
The Argentine black and white tegu.
Facing that threat head on are
UF researchers Jenna Cole and Sarah Cooke.
- How's it goin'?
- Hey, what's up?
- I'm Wes.
- I'm Jenna, nice to meet ya.
- Nice to meet you, too.
(car doors closing)
- [Wes] So we are out here
lookin' for invasive reptiles.
- Yes.
- [Jenna] So we are gonna be looking
for the Argentine black and white tegu.
They are just a huge problem,
preying on our native species.
- [Wes] Tegu populations
have exploded in recent years,
so Jenna and Sarah are painstakingly
trapping and removing them one by one.
So, how many traps are
we gonna be checking?
- [Jenna] So, we've got 160 traps out here.
- [Wes] A long way.
- [Jenna ] Yeah, it's a
pretty extensive trap line.
- [Wes] One hundred and sixty traps spread over miles
of uninhabited marshland.
Where do you even begin?
Well, you start at trap number one.
So, our first trap of the day.
- Yep, this will be the first one.
And it looks like we've got something.
- Oh, cool.
That is so crazy; he's biting at the trap.
Kind of a scary little predator.
Like a little dinosaur.
- [Jenna] Yeah, essentially
they are little dinosaurs.
- Uh-huh, and all you had in this trap
to bait 'em in was a chicken egg?
- Yep, just a single chicken egg.
So, if could imagine a whole
nest of alligator eggs.
(melancholy guitar music)
- I mean, he just looks
like a little egg eater.
But it's not only
alligators that are at risk.
Tegus will eat just about anything.
- [Sarah] The ground
nesting birds, the turtles,
snakes—all of those
animals are potential prey
for these large lizards.
- [Wes] A single tegu
can consume an entire
nest of eggs in one sitting,
so we don't take any chances.
It's straight into the bag for removal.
So, I'm bagging my first tegu here.
There we go.
- [Sarah] You got it.
(trap rattling)
(laughter)
- [Jenna] Up and down like.
- Up and down.
- [Jenna] Yeah.
- There we go.
- [Sarah] Voila.
- [Wes] Cool.
- Tah-dah.
- [Wes] One down.
- [Jenna] Alright.
Let's catch 160 more.
- [Jenna] Right?
- We have to be very conscious of where
we're holding the bag 'cause they can
actually bite you through the bag.
- [Sarah] Definitely.
- [Wes] You've been bit through the bag before.
- Yes.
- [Wes] Ok, cool.
- You also have to watch
if you set the bag down,
they can run away in the bag.
- Yes.
- Oh, really?
- So if you ever have to
set it down on the ground,
we'll step on the bag
while we're doing whatever.
- [Wes] You just see a bag ...
- [Sarah] Oh yeah, the bag just hops away.
(laughter)
- [Wes] That's crazy.
The farther we go, the more apparent it is
just how many tegus are
crawling around out here.
Man, another one down.
Oh, he's excited.
- [Jenna] Got another one, guys.
- [Wes] Oh, we got another one.
- [Sarah] Awesome, grumpy one.
- Yeah, I can't believe how
many there are out here.
There's a ton.
- [Jenna] There is a full
breeding population of them.
- [Wes] Saving the Everglades,
one tegu at a time.
- [Sarah] One tegu at a time.
- [Wes] This is the end of
the line for these tegus.
Each one that Jenna and her team captures
is brought back to the lab and euthanized.
And that's tough for a
reptile-lover like Jenna.
- You really have to
look at a big picture.
I like tegus, and it's unfortunate
that there is no alternative.
But it's not just that we are
removing them, and that's it.
We are using them to learn
more about the species,
so that we can mitigate and prevent them
from causing more terrible damage
than what's going on already.
(ominous guitar music)
- [Wes] Yeah, that's not a small one, huh?
- No, he's not a small one.
- A couple hundred yards from where
we just caught a tegu in this little canal
there's a pretty big alligator
just kinda hanging out.
So it shows that they really
are occupying the same space.
It's not impossible to
imagine a nest around here.
- [Jenna] Oh, he's coming up.
- [Wes] Oh, he's, yeah.
- [Jenna] Heh-heh-heh.
- Wow.
We caught a number of
tegus today out here.
They're from Argentina, originally.
So, how did they get to Florida?
- The general consensus
on how the tegus got here
is through the pet trade.
They were either released or
escaped into the ecosystem.
They're very small and very cute
when they are first
sold and first hatched.
And as the grow people tend to realize
that they may be in for a lot
more than they bargained for.
- And then, in the middle of the swamp,
we come across one very special tegu.
So we've got a tegu here
that has a transmitter on it.
So, I believe, that means that we actually
get to pull him out after we bag him,
and I actually get to get my hands on him.
That's right, right?
- Yep, we're gonna go
ahead and get him out.
- [Wes] In this vast wilderness,
the research team has transmitters
on only six tegus, so it's
a real stroke of luck
that we found this one.
- [Cameraman] What do you think, Wes?
- Pretty cool.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, when they squirm,
you don't grab the tail.
- Yeah.
And that's just 'cause it can detach?
- Yeah, he'll drop it.
- I can definitely tell that
there's some real strength.
We've obviously got a tegu out of the trap
that we're handling, so why is it
that we're able to pull this one out?
- We are actually following him around
and learning more about where he lives
and what he's doing out here, so that we
can learn more ways to effectively
trap and remove them from
this Everglades system.
- He's like a little spy for you guys?
- Yeah, so he's like a double agent.
- [Wes] It's hard to
believe that something
as small as releasing some pet lizards
can threaten the health
of an entire ecosystem.
My time here has proven
to me just how delicate
that balance can be.
The scientists we met from UF are fighting
a daily battle to right
some of our wrongs.
It's hot, humid and frustrating work,
but these biologists care
deeply about native species
and tagging along helped me understand
just how important their battle is.
(frogs croaking)